et bien ça y tombe d'assez squeeze et on
se retrouve aujourd'hui sur la plage
comme et du club avec mon ami est jay z
pour une vidéo particulière en fait je
vais vous expliquer le concept
donc en fait je joue logique je joue et
à chaque mort c'est vous qui devez nous
dire en commentaire ce qu'on doit faire
donc là pour ce premier épisode à chaque
mois mon ami méteren juifs mais belle
mais pour l'avenir la après après avoir
vu la vidéo vous laisser un commentaire
pour dire ce que vous aimeriez que je
fasse ou comme face à chaque mort voilà
je pense que c'est un concept plutôt
marrant qui vous fera bien marrer tout
cas vous allez voir je vais en prendre
pas mal des gifles alors on est donc sur
karachi donc tu n'as pas ralenti
oui je voulais dire bonjour déjà parce
que il m'a pas présentées il ya déjà un
changement d'autres pour que tu parles
c'est voilà voilà
même le je pense à toi en france est
incroyable c'est trop fort je pense que
non non salés aux lentilles et pas être
homologué regretter j'ai tellement il te
met une gifle à vas-y alors voilà je
vois ça commence
ok tu va crescendo genre au début du jeu
c'est paris adam ça me fait marrer mais
ce soir là je parle au nom de tout et
abonnés qui ont tous envie de te mettre
une issue dans les guerrières lui va tu
as ça fait mal on en avait bien fait là
où on prenait de la sauce piquante à
chaque mort
invite à aller voir la ville vous invite
à aller la voir boire un bon os
attention je prépare à aa des baisses
notamment l'espace de chenapan fait j'en
ai plein me plaît alors celle de moi et
je m'en fous je vais tenter comme une
tare du s est mort je trouve pas avec ça
fait trop mal j'ai l'âge ou qui
chauffent la terre at il fait ça alors
attends c'est ce que j'ai fait un petit
chien enfin moi pour parler du jeu alors
modern warfare 2 qui est donc sorti en
2006 voilà les agences jiji
c'est un jeu pas trop connu voilà bon
mais on n'est pas mal quand même dessus
mais mais il a d'ailleurs voilà [ __ ]
donc j'étais sur pc ou si je suis un
commentateur blessé et c'est assez rare
on va perdre mais je suis le gardien
salut salut
non à l armée des mails que vous prenez
si vous voyez ça enfin moore est donc
racontant un peu notre vivant au gabon
donc je rappelle vite fait le concept
pour ça au cas où on aurait quelques
problèmes au cerveau vous suffit donc de
chercher pourquoi être suffisant que de
laisser un commentaire vidéo par exemple
oui à chaque mois je veux que tu boivent
de l'eau salée par exemple vous mettez à
chaque noir au bout en verve de salé par
exemple pourquoi pas montré plutôt bon
c'est pas top comme concept mais c'est
pas mal a jamais l'état mais un peu
moins fort l'énergie quand tu faisais la
joue super chaude je pense que la
prochaine fois on va faire ça avec vos
amis les amis et pourquoi pas c'est quoi
l'idée que parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'a
pas pu on fait face les supermarchés
étaient fermés les bocaux nos moyens
mais c'est tout sinon méthodes et normes
du butin après la jordanie siège conakry
j'adore
passion ben oui tu me l'avais pas ça la
voilà sur les doigts la tournée c'est ta
faute là désolé là c'est le mec qui aime
se promener jc genre à me gêner
non pas bon voilà j'espère que le
conseil vous plaira excellent aura quand
même un peu de succès même beaucoup mais
là non on n'en fait pas de france les ja
qu'on attend bien le goût de la glagla
dans le micro ouais je vous j'en pleure
encore été appelé appelez moi j'aime me
cacher un peu bête
enfin bref alors vous la vue hop hop
et toc et d'abandon oui mais c'est
tellement bon je sais qu'il ya des
milliers de personnes qui voudraient
faire ça oui mais ils ne feront pas et
je peux vous dire que j'ai bien mal on
va mon cas qu'il en soit le commentaire
est assez folle ma foi qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait vous dire dans cette vidéo
j'ai super mal à la joue droite saluent
au revoir retour le retour de la barre
ça lui qui te manque de locaux j'adore
faire des coups de coupes dans les pieds
c'est vrai que ça doit être très utile
et faisait les pieds quand à la guerre
c'est pas déjà rien que le fait de faire
un presqu'au pas la bière ne faut pas un
processeur via comme un mec fait 5360
cheval ou sur un mec moi ta guerre web à
des rappels comedy club ya pas mal de 2
or de vidéos vas-y meilleur des forces
montantes paquet c'est ça des super
force comme tout à la puissante celle là
la rapatriement par le nom de tous les
jeux on va bientôt adhérer vidéo en tout
cas je suis pas trop quand vous parler
d'acte et j'espère tout simplement de ce
concept vous plaira la prochaine feuille
de wasabi vous inquiétez pas on va
chercher des choses à dire qu'on a
trouvé des choses à dire parce que ça
sur marie va parler si on a parlé a
laissé bien des commentaires s'il vous
plaît pas plus j'aime me dira si voilà
si vous aimez ou non ça c'est très
important pour nous vos commentaires
renier et ouais et puis en tout cas j'ai
des fourmis dans la joue c'est assez
stressant
je crois qu'après je vais aller aux
toilettes me font marrer blé prend le
martyre ténor mémoire la place
ça lui mais bon allez alors en tout cas
quoi qu'il en soit j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu vous invite à
l'ajouter dans vos favoris si vous aimez
ce genre de concept et d'en parler à vos
amis s'engagent sais pas j'ai eu cette
idée pour vous tous vous dire j'étais
aux toilettes
j'étais sur le trône quand j'avais eu
cette idée et qu'on a vu comment tu
arrives cliquant salut et ouais je dois
avouer que j'avais bien aimé les
toilettes pour conseil comme aux étoiles
r'way alors elle sur le trône ça donne
pas mal d'idées ont pas moins voilà
écoute et parlez-en à vos amis si vous
aimez bien ce concept et c'est l'essai
ou des commentaires pour dire aux tables
je pense qu'on l'a déjà dit et ce qu'il
veut ouais enfin bon voilà écouter tient
tout le monde bat et à bientôt pour un
nouvel une nouvelle vidéo comme ça je
pense qu'un prochain après avec du
wasabi ou alors avec une de vos idées si
vous en avez des bonnes et en tout cas
je vous dis à bientôt tout le monde ciao
et on se retrouve très bientôt